[Music]
so i don't know if you guys have
uh been paying much attention but tiger
woods is now a [ __ ] billionaire
no
lebron just made it so it's just jordan
lebron and tiger as uh athletes that are
billionaires but those are some of the
big those are obviously the biggest
names
um what got him there because a lot of
the times it's not really like there's
there's more i believe but it's like
their products and investments for
tigers less than 10 of his financial
wealth came from him playing games wow
wow
yep so yeah endorsements is a huge chunk
right um
and obviously
he had he could just do anything like
he'd show up somewhere and they pay him
to show up and yeah all kinds of [ __ ] so
but yeah you know he also made money
from golf earnings but like most of it
like anthony says is like endorsements
and others he even just turned down a
nine figure deal to join the live golf
league the saudi back live golf league
dude tell everybody about this this is
so interesting
how much deal so pretty much um
basically the main league in the entire
golf industry has been the pga for the
last like half century right
professional golf association it's just
the one there's really no competitor
there's no rival league until recently a
saudi-backed group which means they have
[ __ ] tons of money unlimited oil
unlimited they made something called
live golf liv golf and it's a different
type of league and i guess their entire
ethos is to like bring excitement back
to the sport and the shareability of
golf and what they did is they [ __ ]
threw out [ __ ] tons of money to pga tour
contracts in order for them to break
their contracts leave the tour and come
join their golf and there is a heavy
mini golf element heavy mini golf it
reminds me of that [ __ ] clown face
over the clock basically goes
back out there's a bridge there's a
crocodile that opens his mouth and
closes yeah yeah but it's professional
golf there's a windmill
everybody can go you're gonna die clown
and so phil nicholson's like he's like
yeah no i was really ahead until the
clown face and honestly the crocodile
just took me out
and what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do that's the game
buggy on the windmill
that's the game of golf dude and in the
[ __ ] windmill where it's like it
blocks the theme
oh man i didn't know i i follow a couple
like some of my friends and stuff are
heavy involved in golf and i've been
seeing this live golf [ __ ] but i didn't
know what it was like for example
between phil mickelson dustin johnson
who just won the pga i think and then
bryce dechambeau those three by
themselves i think scored like 400 to
500 million uh from the live golf to
leave pga gee
so like they're in these like huge and
again there's no there has never been
again pga is like kind of the do you
know how much they were making
comparatively prior to being
way less like 10x less i believe is it
really more entertaining to watch it's
hard to say because i've been following
golf so long but for example when you
watch like a pj tour or like a
tournament like the us open or the mass
or something like that right there's
like a way there's you know it's kind of
been the same consistency like
if i if you were if you wanted to watch
tiger in a four-day tournament you know
you'd see him tee off at one point and
then you'd like pay attention to a
window which is teeing off in another
day
this one live golf during day two today
that they just finished and all 48
competitors tee off at the same time at
different holes on the same course
so in terms of when you're watching it
on tv and you just showed me this
earlier earlier this is [ __ ] crazy
you're not like following a single group
you're watching everybody and they're
just cutting back to everybody's playing
and then not only they're playing the
individual they're also playing on teams
so they have like four person teams so
there's an individual uh
price a prize bucket and then there's
also a team one and it's way more money
it's like if you [ __ ] are in the top
like for some [ __ ] like that everybody's
walking away with like five million
dollars how do they pick teams have you
guys ever watched nfl red zone
yeah so red zone it's the the whole
thing like if you turn to this channel
it's just everything that's happening
like near the the red zone of the so
like when they're gonna score right so
so it just cuts it just keeps cutting to
all the different teams who are there
because 32 teams playing and like on a
sunday there's probably 20 something
teams so it just keeps cutting to the
action right and that that's what these
guys are innovating on
you're not watching your grandpa's golf
and falling asleep in the [ __ ] chair
you're like actually watching the action
yeah there's a difference between like
watching somebody hit and then like
following that entire shot there's
commentation on it the guy's picking up
his [ __ ] [ __ ] with his caddy they're
walking down the field too slow and
they'll cut into a commercial because
they're waiting for somebody to get to
the next hole because they're televising
that
versus this one it's like the second
some guy hits a shot you see where it
lands you're cutting to the next major
player watching their [ __ ] many
others to cut to
so
tiger was offered to join ilv golf with
a nine
figure offer that's good nine figures
said he turned it down he turned it down
so he's already turned it down because
of endorsements like monster energy and
like all these other um and he says i
don't care he's like i don't care i want
to play golf the way i want to [ __ ] my
girls i'm gonna [ __ ] my hoes and my
[ __ ] porn stars yeah and ain't
nothing you can do about it because i'm
talking about the [ __ ] woods and i
don't have inland to hold me down
anymore i guess that makes sense if
you're a billionaire like people can't
really pay you to do that much at that
point yeah no way
hey straight up though michael jordan
lebron james target was like you got to
give it up to the black people who
[ __ ] whoop everybody's asses
billionaires in the game outside of the
game by the way tiger woods i mean look
i know that he's behind jack nicholas in
the in the amount oh yeah the amount of
masters oh no not masters just overall
um
tournament championship yeah he made
everyone more interested in golf he made
golf cool he made golf cool exactly and
he allowed people who are not white to
play on certain of course
what makes him like the jordan of golf
like is he does he play a certain way he
was undeniable like and then even in the
late 90s i remember in i was in like san
diego i'm in elementary school and my
teacher like pulls out the [ __ ] tv
cart
to play just tiger woods playing in the
open because he was there does he play
he's just electrifying well number one
he was during a time where like uh there
was no black people black people
couldn't go on certain country clubs
yeah they couldn't go into the country
yeah
they still had segregation and jews it
was black people and jews couldn't do it
so even nike's first campaign with tiger
they chose the first marketing campaign
to be about like it's like tiger [ __ ]
slow-mo shots and they're like you won't
let me play on some of your courses but
i'm about to bring it you know what i
mean so it's one of those things where
they're trying to kind of hit that edge
and stuff but tiger specifically won
he he [ __ ] had
most gangster drives like he was like if
people were knocking like 250 260 on
drive he was starting to hit like 300
yarders and plus dang but his short game
was also undeniable whether it be his
chipping or his putting from a heavily
crazy shot so this guy was uh for an era
consistently beating every major pro by
like 10 strokes in the tournament which
is like undeniable also his people to
his credit had a masterful plan because
like what randomly was saying earlier
we're like he's on this reality show and
um it's about so you think you dance but
they why are they cutting to his [ __ ]
family home life it's because they're
they're selling the story of him so that
you're rooting for him even more and
that's what happened to tiger they cut
to his dad his dad teaching him they had
footage of him he's so different yeah
yeah and his dad's like teaching when
he's a kid i want to be a big time
golfer i'm a little [ __ ]
seven-year-old kid i pick my boogers and
eat them
and that that worked on people because
it just made people want to root for him
even more and it it
you know he exploded not just because he
was killing the golf game but because of
his story and he also was so talented
that he did an innovative whatever is
now called the tiger slam where he won
uh all four
major championships in one run in one
year so he was the only person i believe
to ever hold all four championships he's
also the only um as far as i'm aware the
only black golfer who was ever drafted
by the white people in the in the
racetrack
i remember that [ __ ] that was great yeah
and that was a big deal at the time
monumental everybody was waiting for it
i was so i remember i was staying up all
night to watch it and i was so [ __ ]
nervous the asians were hoping we could
get them back yeah i remember that and
but then when when the whites got him i
remember just hugging my dad and crying
and then my dad was like
it was a big deal he's like i can't
[ __ ] believe this happened it was a
huge wave yeah i mean i do feel like he
belongs more with the white crowd though
you know like he is part asian but it's
hard to claim you know you know he's
more asian than black right i know i
know but the the the feeling that i get
is he does it it's a rifle draft he
loves white women though yeah i mean you
know yeah he loves him i feel cuz just
like just like when we got the wu-tang
clan i felt like that was a good pick
and it was a rifle pick i thought it was
a good pick but i remember just being
relieved that we got tiger already so
like i was like yeah just let it happen
do you think the pga is like [ __ ]
right now
the pga it's it well really depends on
how you see it but the pga just actually
formally put out a statement regarding
this where they have now suspended any
pla because even the players who leave
the pj a tour usually even if you don't
participate in the tour you can still if
you have the right rankings and scores
you can still participate in the tour
tournaments like the major championships
but now the pga has explicitly pretty
much said if you like go join live call
you can't even come to the turn like wow
and guess what phil nicholson said i
have 160 million reasons to say [ __ ] you
don't give a [ __ ] yeah that's ridiculous
that's why the pga is like i mean dude
honestly the way they televise golf is
dog [ __ ] it's dog [ __ ] it's baffled
anything old is gonna get [ __ ]
forgotten and things are gonna be moving
you know nothing is exempt from that
that's true yeah it hasn't been
innovative for 30 years yeah exactly you
think they would have done that by now
that's the way we like it yeah i gotta
say i was watching live golf today
because it was round two and that show
was more exciting than any pga thing i
was showing to me and i couldn't believe
it i was like golf is [ __ ] fun to
watch actually sure like finally cause
actually like the whole thing that
everyone says right is like when you're
there in person it's totally different
than the game and most golfers don't
even watch televised golf because it's
so different in the game and if you've
ever been to a hockey game by the way
televised hockey is different than real
life hockey show right hockey's sick
hockey's [ __ ] wrong live it's so sick
but televised it's dog [ __ ] yeah it's a
lie
figure out how to do it dude the way the
puck moves around i don't know if they
know how to televise it yet the same way
like the way that it just translates
when you're there like it's just
different so but football probably the
best way to televise something i'm
obviously soccer the same way football
is also good though because football's
so grand that if television helps you
see things yeah you know what i mean
well my cheap ass is in the [ __ ] like
hell the nose bleeds and you win a
football game but
when it comes to [ __ ] golf and you're
sitting there and you're like trying to
hold on pretend like you like it and
they're like whispering as commentators
and you're waiting [ __ ] 15 minutes
for the guy to choose his clothes and
[ __ ] but it almost it almost felt like
it was meant to be that way like i feel
like when when i was younger and i saw
golf i was like oh this is made for me
to not like it because it's not for me
i'm at the library that's how it felt
like it felt like they weren't trying
because it's like oh don't worry you're
not invited anyway so it's like good i'm
glad you don't like it
now cause like for example they just did
the [ __ ] celebrity match where tom
brady is is teamed up with was aaron
rodgers and then patrick mahomes is with
um with um josh allen from the buffalo
bills yeah so you now not before they
would have like celebrity quarterbacks
maybe partner with like a pga tour
champion or something like that and then
that'll be the celebrity match now you
just got four [ __ ] huge quarterbacks
just going at it everybody's missing
their putts they're talking [ __ ] the
whole time
you know what i mean that's what you
want but then yeah it just seems like uh
there's with a lot of sports there's a
bunch of like ain't broke don't fix it
kind of attitudes which is such a
mistake because they're making enough
money so they can justify it but it's
like you don't have to innovate ever but
then all it takes is another company to
come out here there's gonna be
exactly the beauty of it
live golf sponsored by live golf dude
live golf is [ __ ] coming to you dude
yeah dude coming to your [ __ ] face
come into your face let's play that's
their [ __ ] tagline
you